تحت وسم الهويه اليمنيه تنتشر هذه الايام
على مواقع التواصل اجتماعي حمله يمنيه
نسائيه معتمده على استعراض الزي اليمني
النسائي الحمله تاتي رفضا لاجراءات
ميليشيا بفرض القيود المشدده على لباس
المراه في مناطق اليمن حيث يقتصر لباس على
ارتداء العبايات الناشطات اعتمدنا على
الاثواب اليمنيه التقليديه المزركشه
والملونه بالكثير من الالوان المبهجه التي
اعتادت اليمنيات على ارتدائها طوال حياتهم
فيما تؤكد انشطات المشاركات في الحمله
الانتماءهن للالوان وعدم الاستسلام ورفض
سياسه اللون الواحد نفسيا والقيود التي
تفرض على السيدات
[موسيقى]
وبما اننا نتحدث عن الازياء اليمنيه
سنحتفي معها بهذه الازياء وبتنوعها الزي
العدني وهو الثوب الذي تلبسه النساء في
منطقه عدن وما حولها ويتميز بالوانه
المختلفه وبلمسات ذهبيه اللون الزي
الصنعاني وهو الزي الذي تلبسه النساء في
صنعاء وضواحيها ويتكون من فستان اسمه
الزنه وعليه العصبه او المصعر والتي توضع
على الراس وهو مزين بالحلي الفضيه ويسمى
الرش الزي التعزيه يعود واصله ازاي
التعديل الدوره الحميريه يتكون الزيت من
الثوب وهو المكون الرئيسي ويطلق عليه
القميص بالاضافه الى السروال والمصار
والمجرمه
الزي اليافعي يعود لمنطقه يافا اليمنيه
القريبه من لحج ويعد احد اجمل الازياء
النسائيه اليمنيه حيث يجمع بين البساطه في
الزرقشه والزينه والالوان الجميله
والحزام المذهب او الفضي الذي يحيط الخصر
مالحه عن الثوب الكثير من الالق والجمال
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
تنضمي العين من رباط العالميه والكاتبه
اليمنيه لارا دراسي لارا يسعد صباحك اهلا
بك نتعرف معك على الزي اليمني متوارث
للنساء اليمنيات
صباح الخير من بدري امانه كلها يا طير
يصحي كل متابعين العربيه
يعني لارى اليوم امام حدا زي الذي ترتدينه
الزي الصنعاني الى اي حد لو تحدثين اكثر
بان الثقافه والتاريخ اليمني هو مرتبط
بهويه وزي المراه اليمنيه يعني عندما
نتحدث عن المراه اليمنيه يا لارا نتحدث عن
المثال الاول للنساء العربيات في منطقتنا
المراه اليمنيه هي ملكه
الملكه بلقيس ملكه اليمن النساء في اليمن
الحضارات السابقه السابقه وحمير وحضر موت
نجد الكثير من الرموش الكثير من السماء
بالعقيقه اليماني يتزيننا بالملابس
هي منطقه في اليمن لها هويتها الخاصه جدا
انها تفردها وهوايتها الكامله في سحر
الجمال بمعنى
المناطق الجنوبيه
مثلا فهي مناطق تعتمد على الدرع العدني
المشهور جدا
على الذي كان لا يوجد
[موسيقى]
والشيزر العراقي لهم تشابه نوعا ما
المناطق الوسطى المناطق الحضرميه الثوب
الشهريه الثوب السيئوني بنات المكلا هو
عباره عن قطعه من
المخمل يكون مزين من الاشخاص من تحت الثوب
ويكون مزين همم
سكر للمراه وهي تسير انت عارفه جمال كانوا
يقطف الاسد
اولا اسمحي لي ابدا اعجابي بالزي اليمني
يعني فعلا من شماله لجنوب ولا منطقه الشرق
الغرب يعني في تنوع كبير وفي شغل واضح
ومجهود على الزيت بس انا ما يثير فضولي
يعني انا من خلال ما رايت من خلال الصور
اللي عرضناها زي محتشم زي راقي
وزي فعلا جميل لماذا يخشى الحوثي من هذا
الزي ويخشى ان ترتديه النساء
همم
ولا احد باختصار يمكن ان يقتل الضوء جميله
وباهلا لانه يمانيا في الاصح يعني
يقتل احد الضوء على فكره هذه هذه
اللي يتحدث
معه
بمحبه النساء
في المنطقه
شعر
يعني يتغزل به
ولا ولا ايضا موقف يعني لا اقول لك ان
هناك احد يستطيع ان يحصل الضوء يستطيع ان
يخبئ هذه الالوان الالوان جميله
ومحترم ونحب الجمال
بالتاكيد نحن نتمنى ان تتلون حياهكم تماما
كما ازياءكم وتراكم الذي يخص المراه في
اليمن شكرا جزيلا لكن من الرباط الاعلاميه
والكاتب اليمنيه